I played it this game is garbage
I'll show okay I'll show you look look
okay just look you go you go in and
there's these [ __ ] guys how do I
speak hey listen listen shut the [ __ ] up
get off the stage listen I put on a
shirt No shut up get off get off the
stage you suck you suck
you're about as funny as a celery legit
femme get off get off the stage you
should you're something fuck-ups I'm not
gonna listen to this
put on a shirt and get a job go home
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
what is wrong with you get off this
stupid don't work I will fight you how
dare you kick me out you kick me out one
more time and I swear to God I will go
up on stage and squeeze your nipples so
hard milk will come out you [ __ ] god
fine fine say a joke then say the joke
I'm waiting say the joke
so quite say the joke did
stupid get off thank God thank [ __ ]
god
all right let's say listen you want a
real joke all right my relationship
[ __ ] your this yogurt you got weak no
I'm Shrek sings some other girls god
dammit god dammit hog who kicked me up
why does all these [ __ ] people
play this game I don't get it I don't
get it it's the only room available and
this game is like one free professional
oh wow this is fun
it's just me so anyway ladies am i right
gotta respect them
[Music]
my best friend what my [ __ ] idiot
that's where you're from I'm from your
mom's [ __ ] that's right James so bad
like why do people want me to play it
these guys don't know how to salad ask
Gary mess what does that mean what a
scary mess mean in Turkey it means not
allowed I'm not allowed in this room so
[ __ ] you [ __ ] what are you gonna do huh
what are you gonna do I'm okay sing
saying I'm listening wait am i music
this is really good that was really good
there
[Music]
hey now somebody
[Applause]
[Music]
in this is pretty good
Wow no I was rising no no no you [ __ ]
your bank
keep singing I love it
[Music]
[Applause]
you're terrible wow that's really good
Wow is that you rapping good times no
racism you go down it's a don't make a
joke make a joke
[Applause]
okay you sound like a Betty tale there's
no Z on the back of his car it took
three hours to get me out of it look
kill yourself yoyoyo salad stop us
wouldn't look like a veggie tale and you
sound like a mustache tonight this is
worse than Amy Schumer's Netflix special
does anybody know how to line for the
Chinese men yo you sound black why you
whitening okay
please excuse my digital blackface this
has been comment a night thank you guys
so much for watching leave a leave a
thumbs up if you enjoyed and I will see
you guys next time goodbye squad fam out
[Music]